They have that much computing power
going through. We don't need it. Right.
>> Funny.
>> Exactly. That's exactly what they would
do. What is this guy planning to do
here?
>> Yeah.
>> So, I'm going to
like steal here. We'll hire him. He's
still in the country. We don't have to
pay.
>> He's here. The thing is that it's 18
weeks, [ __ ]
That's like what the hell bad like is
there any way and get this faster? No,
>> you have to ship it to old block first.
>> It's about right. Yeah.
that knows that I'm in Austin.
So, I don't want to
see this is see this one of the reasons
why I've been here for so long is I've
been trying to get resources like this
before I leave. And this is a good a
good example of like something that I'd
have to buy today and not when by the
time it arrives here, I'm not planning
on being in Austin. So that window is
shortening out, right? So then I have to
go buy a used one which I don't want
like because I want to get a new uh okay
rich person problem. Sorry.
I know it's it's I know it's a problem.
It's
>> or or you'll just have to like call
around say hey which store has this spec
available and then they ship and then
>> but it doesn't have it doesn't have the
overkill one. I want it real overkill.
>> So okay. So what do you mean by
overkill? Like for example, you did uh
M3 chip. You don't want M4 chip.
>> No, there it's M4. It's M4. Watch.
>> No, it's not. It's M3.
>> Oh, okay. Hold on.
How did I get that wrong? Okay, hold on.
M4. There.
Okay.
Set package now. Make sure.
>> Oh. Oh. So, it def it defaults to M3
Ultra. So, is M3 Ultra bigger than M4?
Okay.
>> No, that's impossible.
>> That's what they're saying.
That's what they're saying. Cuz if you
try to get if you try to get uh the uh
the uh the best package with the with
the most RAM, it's going back to M3,
>> [ __ ] Well, see, they're both 16 to 18
weeks.
>> Why? Why? What the What the
>> Oh, also
a good point. You probably want to wait
just a few days. WWC is from the 8th to
the 12th, so they might drop Who knows
if they're going to drop any hardware,
but I wouldn't be surprised if they drop
something with M5.
>> Okay.
>> And then that'll drop the price. That'll
drop the price of these if you want
still want to go with this with the M4.
But
>> that would mean I'd need to go to the
Netherlands for like 6 weeks and then go
right back to United States and have my
get my studio when it arrives and then I
go to South America afterwards.
That would be so this.
>> Yeah, Rich.
>> Theo's going to get this now, then he's
going to get the new one later and give
this to somebody at the conclave.
>> Okay, I like you guys.
>> There we go. That's a good idea. Bravo.
>> Yes, sir.
>> Okay.
I give it to the next coup. Serge,
>> I I I like
I I like you guys. I don't love you guys
like that. Okay. I like you. You guys
are No, no. This is me for keeping this
>> You can you can order it and have it
delivered to whatever Apple store is
going to be in the place.
>> No, no, no, no. Because if I'm doing
this internationally
and I have it delivered someplace else,
do you know what they have
internationally?
>> VAT.
>> This thing called tax.
>> Yep.
>> Value added tax. Yes. VAT.
>> We know.
>> There we go. VAT. You said VAT.
>> So that's like 25%. Or in France it
could be much higher or Brazil it could
be like 100%.
Depending. So no. No, I'm not willing to
pay an apple. No, no, no, no. I'm not
doing that. I will fly my ass back.
>> Send it to New York and just do a quick
little or wherever whatever city that
you're going.
>> Send it to me. I'll fly it out to you.
Just me on first class. It's cheaper
than paying the taxes.
>> I never hear Michael again.
I don't I Where did Michael go? I don't
know. Bye. Bye.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Anyway, um yeah, good idea,
guys. And anyway, um I will get a
computer then. I'll just go travel with
it. I need something powerful.
So, I have to go get I hope the M5 comes
out for the Mac. Wait, is it M5 out for
the MacBook Pro?
>> I don't think so.
>> But but like Jo said, is still
>> We're two days away from
>> Yeah. from the Apple conference.
>> Oh, it has a Mac and it has Max. It
doesn't have Ultra.
>> The The Ultra is what we're waiting on.
That That might drop during WWC.
>> Okay. So, Ultra I want M5 Ultra cuz
>> yeah,
>> my M3 now properly works. It like it
isn't psycho. I got it to work
correctly. Oo, it's a nice machine. I
like it. I'm very happy with it. That
had that was a fourth uh rebuild.
Finally worked.
Uh Ultrabook still need the touch. I
believe in touch so much.
I seen computing power. Anyway, uh this
is Sore. We have a little bit of fun
with you guys. So, um we've been
building up to soar and the last few
labs and we have the token being issued,
right? Uh so our whole thing is we're
trying to figure out whether or not a
token is been used or not and we're
trying to get some automation on this.
So this is what today what our lab we're
doing now is going to be uh how to get
AI to do automation for us. Okay. So
guys might say what is sort I wrote this
all out basically
um
people who don't know just so you can
run through and just get some sort of
introduction. I put this in here and
I'll probably modify this later on. I'm
trying to I'm probably be making a
manual for this later on uh for future
classes. Okay. So if you want security
we need to know sword. Yeah. Okay. So
the big problem that you have with in a
nutshell, the big problem that you have
with security is that you have an alert
but nobody does anything about it. It
just an alert. So it's like who cares?
And that's because you don't have the
ability to do anything about it. You
just don't uh you don't have enough
staff, you know, you don't you have some
detection mechanisms, but nothing really
happens. So with soore what you're doing
is uh also yeah alert fatigue same thing
just too many alerts we don't know
what's going on and we have here again
thousands of logs millions of logs
thousands of alerts so just too much
that's ridiculous so uh sort is a way of
automating
responses and if you use AI in here it's
even better okay so again it says alert
human reads it then human watches
YouTube a few hours human investigates
After a few days, human opens tickets.
Maybe human responds after payday,
right?
This is this is really true.
I I think about myself at work. I'm I'm
doing all this vulnerability analysis
and I get tired and I'm like, I don't
want to do this right now. I got other
things to do. So, I just go walk for a
while and then I go do YouTube for a
while or something like that and go
exercise downstairs. Exactly. It's
exactly correct. All right. So the human
can't human has limitations like ah this
is too much right. So again sort changes
the model event automated detection
automatic enrichment automated decision
automatic response human escalation of
lead. Okay so key idea humans should
handle judgment automation should handle
repetition sore in the lab you're
already building the foundation. So
basically this is the big thing you
don't want the decision or the ultimate
judgment to be with AI but the decision
trees should be implemented by AI.
Please understand that the
responsibility and the ultimate judgment
is with the human. The decision trees is
with AI or automated features. This is
why you though when we're talking about
AI being used with security, the human's
role has got to change. So the human it
it's more important for the human to
have better discernment uh capabilities
uh more intense knowledge of like CVEes
and weaknesses and things like that
because a human needs to know what to do
in the context of what the alerts are
what the alerts are coming in. But the
actual separation of of logs, the actual
initial treatment of logs, that should
always be done with automated features
so that the human can only pay attention
to what's really valuable. Okay. Oh,
you're you have fun Carlton. All right.
So the current workflow yeah the user
logs in issue token issue token unused
event bridge text behavior alert
generated. Okay. So this is already a
lightweight store environment. Okay. So
now um we have for example you have a
suspicious login from banana land. I
don't know what banana land is. I have
no idea. I wonder what that is. I have
no idea. So the user authenticates from
unusual location. Sor workflow
triggered. Enrich IPU reputation. Check
MFA status. Notify Slack. Notify SNS
again. Create Jerro tickets. disable
account if high risk. This is something
you can do uh with AI automation. What I
would say ultimately is this disable
account uh shouldn't be automated. It
should be done with human judgment. But
only do automation if you get prior
approval for this because this can [ __ ]
things up. Uh Rob, what do you got? Um
when you're referring to the user to
this uh runbook, we'll call it runbook.
Uh would there only be a a quality check
gate when it came to this step or would
there be other steps where you would
want to have human quality checks uh for
the runbook?
>> Um I would want it to hear on on this
last part. That's the only that's the
only part that that you would require or
require a a human check.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Because if Okay, so this is the
reason is because if AI is being used
here and does an automatic disable, if a
if a hacker knows this or suspects it,
then they could run an attack on every
single user on the company and disable
everyone.
>> Oh, that that so you bring up a good I
just remembered something. This may be
helpful. So what Theo says is uh correct
where where if the hacker knows that
this is an automatic deploy then it will
just uh mess everything up. There's a
there was a a fire ship video I saw
about the mpm uh uh dependency getting
uh getting basically getting hacked. Um
the m long story short the um mpm is a
is used with the python and others and
and and is a big part of the software
supply chain. uh has used a lot of
Python, used a lot of AI and basically
uh a attacker uh injected malicious code
into that codebase and they injected
malicious code into a pull into a pull
request for the uh mpm uh GitHub repo.
and they knew that the mpm GitHub repo
whenever there's a pull request it does
automatic pipeline run. So they injected
they injected that bad code then they
cancel the the pull request but GitHub
still will see that the pull request was
requested and then it was canceled but
it still is trying to honor that
request. So it will run the pipeline
with that bad code and then after a
certain point all the other additions
downstream have that bad code which
basically broke npm for a while. So it
was it was devious but it was smart. But
that's why, you know, this disable this
disabled account or or trying just just
asking like, hey, when do I use human
judgment or how when do I use a human
quality check or a hum a gate for humans
to verify that everything is good?
That's why I'm asking cuz you when you
have these types of attacks, it can
[ __ ] a a company real fast.
>> Yeah. So like what this is another
reason why if you guys look at my uh
LinkedIn you'll know that I don't use my
real last name. I never do and any
public site I never use my real last
name. Why? Okay it's very simple. If
they know your real last name and then
they can figure out the naming
convention for email for a company so
that all they'd have to do is go on to
LinkedIn and figure out all the
employees who work at the company. You
notice I don't put the company to work
out either. So you all you do is get the
naming convention. You get the names and
then you get the company. Then you just
make a script to create what the most
likely email accounts are based upon the
the logic basically how the company
probably does it. And then you just run
a a direct account direct account attack
against all those accounts
simultaneously.
Well,
I mean it's not that hard to do. It's
it's for a good hacker that's about an
hour of work,
right? So if you run that against me, go
ahead. You ain't going to get me. I
don't have enough information on my
LinkedIn to do that. I'm fine.
People when I see people do um
especially security guys put their real
name on LinkedIn. I'm like, are you sure
you're a real security guy? I mean, are
you sure, bro? Because that's a public
are you serious?
Like, come on, man. Like, you don't do
that [ __ ] Anyway, Dale, what you got?
>> Thank you for bringing up LinkedIn. You
actually read my mind, but from a
different perspective. The way that you
were describing Soore. It It reminds me,
uh, my group said that we all had to
sign up for a LinkedIn account and then
LinkedIn banned me immediately and I
think it was automated. Then I had to go
through a whole process to try to prove
myself even with my ID and it was it
still said no automated and then I had
to probably reach out to a human person
and that person gave me access.
So is it a situation like that where too
much is being left in the hand of the
AI?
>> No this case something is being wrong
something is wrong with the AI in that
time. they did something wrong with the
programming the filters with AI it's
that's an overcorrection but it is it's
done okay so for an initial signup
denying you for there that's wrong um
but
they have to have some sort of filter to
an for initial signups anyway because
the Russian hackers come in and the
Chinese hackers so that's I don't have a
problem with that um
>> I to follow up on that. One other thing
that I that I think could be the issue
is um I think my company pays for some
maintenance education stuff. So they
might have an account for me that I do
not use
>> and that's why they're saying this
actually the same person even though I
don't use the other account and it was
create it was it could be created for
me.
>> No, no idea. If you have all you all I
can say is um change your IP address
like go to go to Starbucks, use a
different browser, create a new Gmail
account or like Hotmail account,
something like that and then try to make
a LinkedIn and see what happens.
>> No, I I eventually got through but um
like you said, I had to reach a human to
to
>> No, see if you can do it without the
human.
>> Without the human. If you're able to do
if you do that process and you're able
to make the account, then you know is
something that's on your computer which
AI automatically rejected.
>> That's why
>> and the last thing is you're saying we
shouldn't be using our real name on
LinkedIn at all.
>> Nope.
>> Got you. So if your name is Michael Dale
legally,
you should say Michael and then
modify Dale or just use a different last
name
>> like d a y or d
i l e or spell something wrong or
nickname or middle name or something.
>> Yeah,
>> got you.
>> Say Obama. I don't care. I I put a name.
put it just something else.
>> But my last name like again for public I
never use my last name.
>> Never. Impossible.
>> Right. But so so I would I would also
say that you know I' I've had to I've
I've been run this experiment as well
guys. Like I I had my my primary account
with all my connections was found by my
boss. I had to clear it out so I
couldn't use it for applying to jobs. I
had to create a second one. I've been
getting noble traction and all the only
people that are my friends on that alias
account are recruiters. So, I get I get
fair amount of traction and views and
all that fun stuff. So, if you use a and
ultimately they only care about your
name when they're submitting you to the
company. Outside of that, everything is
pretty much ATS. So, as long as they're
submitting you to the company and you
start talking with the recruiter, they
start knowing who you are to get you on
the phone, talk to their hiring manager,
at that point, they'll know like, "Oh,
this is not um MDZ, this is Michael
Dale. Okay, we can work with that."
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's that's true.
I've had um people do this so you know
I've had like FBI do background checks
on and they say like give me give like
you want to know your public or uh
social media profile and I said I don't
have any go try to find it prove me
wrong they couldn't prove it they
couldn't prove I had a Facebook account
I was like that's right [ __ ] like I
know what I'm doing right I was like
bring it freak it on
I remember one FBI agent told me, he
said, "You you don't look it, but boy,
you're incredibly intelligent and we
have to take you seriously."
I was I was honored by it. I was
laughing. It's like, you know what's
going on. You don't you don't play by
normal rules like just following the
like sheep. You you actually know what
the rules are and you play according to
the rules. Yeah.
So, again, I like that. That was that
was kind of a cool thing. Um, so always
make sure that your digital profile can
only be verified
through
nothing. It's impossible to verify.
That's what I was saying. Nobody knows
who you are. Um, the only place where I
have a photo of myself. Well, so my
Facebook one is digitally altered right
now. LinkedIn is the only place where I
actually do have a real photo of true.
That's That's me and Katrina, right?
Yep.
Anyone who knows what they are doing
will have a difficult getting caught.
Yeah. Fence Bened's not friendly with
those guys.
Yeah. So, the photos, you can put a
photo on there, but as you notice, the
photos I have in my current Facebook is
is is
enhanced with AI, right? It's it's like
there's a filter out there as a change.
One of the students did that. Um that's
one of the best ways of doing it. Just
be try to remove your real photos. Make
sure there's some sort of filter. Um, I
learned this technique from I I told you
about um the prostitute that I was
tracking for a few years and I couldn't
figure out like my matchmaker in
introduced me to her and she looked like
this charming like young woman and
everything, right? I was thinking,
"Yeah, of course I'm going to make
babies with you, right?" And I just her
story didn't pan out. And I kept on
tracking her, checked her Instagram
photos that she sent me and everything.
And what I found out was that her
Instagram was actually her. That was
that was realistically it was her, but
the photos that she sent me all had
filters. And if if you did normal
searches online or even with an app that
her filtered photos and her Instagram
would never meet up like kept on
searching like went
crazy. I use o OENT OS I NT based
applications
and I finally found her escort profile
and I I I found her photos and those
photos were also somewhat digitally
modified so that the the photos that I
received from the matchmaker and the
photos for her whoring profile would
never reconcile style with each other.
So, I actually had to like I had to use
open chat GPT and I used all of her
photos together and her um what was it?
Her LinkedIn. No, not LinkedIn. Uh her
Instagram and I said these two photos
here have filters. This is real. What is
the degree of overlap? And there these
again try to remove filters. And uh
Tatto did a reverse filter basically and
said, "Yep, that's her. That's
definitely her. That's that's if you got
the right person." And I had to go
through very small areas on her body and
it came all you It's kind of funny. It
came to the ring on her belly button.
The ring on her belly button was one of
the few areas that had no filter and it
was it was the same in all three areas.
Gotcha, [ __ ] You a hoe. Right. So, you
have to go through a lot of of process
there. That's that's a lot of work,
right? FBI really isn't going to be
doing it. Well, if if you're smart, you
don't have stuff like your photo. If
you're not showing your body like that,
I'll li the the pixels can't be
correlated with that with multiple
photos, right? But she got caught. I got
her. I remember I sent that letter to
her. I said men own your body. I own
panata.
You use as I said you use panata and men
use your body. I use I buy panata.
Right. I have the best I have the best.
Anyway, um
hold on. The intel community is very
interested. Folks who are good at this,
you will if you get sloppy get on the
radar. Yep. Yeah. Yeah.
Uh
spokes for that. Most tend to be NSA or
CI.
Yeah, I've done I've done work on here
and it it's it's fascinating. This is
why I just found another girl. Okay,
small side track, but I just found a
woman I've known since 2019. No, 2018.
Finally found her only fans. Use the
same profile. Took me forever. I said,
"Something's not correlating with you.
Gotcha." Right. It's like boom. Gotcha,
[ __ ] All right. I know what you're
doing. That's how you get money. All
right. Uh anyway, uh so you got user
authentication from usual. Okay, this is
what we're talking about here for for
automation. Um so you when we're using
AI with security, just remember when it
comes to actions, you really need to
have the human there. Uh in the pipeline
that I made, which I have to properly
demo for you guys, I have to get that up
and running again here. Um there's a way
of doing automated changes to your code
uh based upon uh dev sec ops or some
sort of automated code that you're
you're running in your pipeline and
especially Terraform. You could actually
I had it so that uh AI could change the
the Terraform in order to remove or in
order to uh be compliant with with
security scans.
You can't you can't have an automatic
deployment
is just no. You cannot do that because
if you're any bit smart then you know
how to manipulate that AI into acting in
a certain way to get you unauthorized
access. And that's exactly what Methos
did. So one AI can convince another AI
to do something. Why is this important?
Because the hackers are developing their
own AI systems and they have them now.
So they can use AI based attacks or AI
based adversarial attacks to convince
your AI to do what it wants it to do.
Again, sounds a little bit like science
fiction or James Bond or something like
that. It's happening now. It's there.
I'm telling you it is. All right. So,
let's go ahead and have some fun here.
Um
so here modern engineers must understand
identity telemetry automation detection
and response flows. Okay. So, telemetry,
we're looking at your error messages,
uh, in particular, your your structure,
um, your hardware infrastructure-based
error messages. You really need to know
what's going on there. Um, patch
management, things like that. Uh, some
login, but
basically, you want to know something's
going wrong in your environment. And if
you know it, if you can get some idea of
what's going on, then start responding
to it. uh for the most part when it
talks about telemetry not that many
people do anything with it. So like some
code is out of date or um you know
there's some sort of routing problem and
packets aren't being routed the correct
way for an application or something like
that. Unless it's a it's a high or a
critical uh alert, people don't do
anything. They don't even watch it just
the way it is because they don't have
enough resources. Now why don't they
have enough resources?
It's because they're usually a bunch of
cheap ass bastards who don't want to
hire more people even for India to go
solve things because they want to
increase shareholder value.
This is where uh sea suite need to be
careful walking down the street.
Not that I know about that. I don't know
why I know anything about that
>> bad thing.
I understand uh when we come I look at
my current company right now and the
amount of frustration that I'm having
with with certain issues because we have
over a million um uh vulnerabilities
vulnerability finding right now
and we have um VMs which have been
running since uh 2022 and they have
never been torn down even once and they
haven't been patched even once and I'm
telling them like we need to actually
develop the program for this because we
have a trillion dollars in assets and
you know we have issues we have to go
deal with these right so why don't we
even
like let's get some people in India to
do it if we can't get people in the
first world to do it fine let's let's go
to India get some guys to do it and then
you know hire them out no won't even do
that I'm like why Because if these
databases get knocked out or these
applications get knocked out, the the
loss we're going to have is is quite
huge, you know, uh so it might be a few
million dollars. So that justifies
getting some budget. Why don't we get $2
million in a year, hire some contractors
out to get some work done? Won't do
ser this is this this is a very
frustrating thing. So uh that's why the
important work isn't being done. They're
trying to automate it which but a lot of
this work can't be done through
automation. Right.
Uh I saw I saw an uptrend knowledge of
open telemetry but still superficial.
The response time is not exploited all
just collective analysis. Yep. Yep.
Correct. Okay. All right.
Yeah.
So in whiz
if if you're using whiz there's um you
could do a search filter and you could
say is this internet facing and does it
have a known public exploit.
So you put I put those two on there and
I said okay let's
let's um let's see how many
vulnerabilities we have and with just
those two alone I think we had over
120,000.
I also said no known no duplicates. So
we had over 120,000
high and critical
vulnerabilities.
I was like are you trying like are you
just trying to make it easy for the
hackers? Like what's going on? So that
that's some crazy [ __ ] I'm just saying
like they should take care of it and
they're not. They're not. They're just
not.
They're like Theo get it. Try to patch
it all without having to spend money.
What? Are you serious?
Oh, Jesus. Anyway, um here we go. So,
SOAR versus SIM. Okay, here we go. Say
here you go. So, SIM collect and analyze
logs. SOAR automate response workflows.
All right, so SIM something suspicion
happened. SOAR SOAR is security as
workflow automation detection without
response is incomplete.
All right. So something suspicious
happened. So I automatically
enriched data created tickets alerted
Slack disabled access. All right. Now
here again
this this is my what I say ultimately
you can go through here and do enrich
data created tickets and alert in Slack.
Um I wouldn't go to a full level of
disable access. Uh just be careful with
that. Don't recommend I you need to
review access. You only disable access
if it's for certain users.
Make sure your security team does not
have disabled access access and also
your cues.
Okay.
So let's map this to current class.
Let's let's look what you guys already
have. All right. You have kita which is
identity. You have lambda got the two
lambda. Lambda is running right. So that
one is actually looking for the token
which is expired right? So you have an
automation engine. Then you have Dynamo
DB. Why do we have that? Because it has
state tracking,
right? I need to know that state. We
need to monitor it. We need to maintain
it. Event bridge as orchestration,
right? Sending from one to another. It
orchestrates the events, right? You have
WFT, you have edge protection, and then
you have Cloudatch, which is telemetry.
It gives you your basic air logs, error
messages. So, it tells you what's
basically going on. So, this is already
building soul.
See why I did it the way I did it?
Evil mastermind. That's right. I was
doing so from from the beginning when I
was doing this. So, you have multiple
AWS services. operating event driven
security and identity aware automation.
Okay,
there you go. Well, this is my little
introduction into serve. Um, any
questions at this point?
Have to go through and edit this again.
I always have to edit it.
Questions?
We good, Rob? Rob. Um, so you touched on
it um, briefly, but
in the the prospect of companies making
their own like their own AI powered
sock. Uh, you touched on it briefly
yesterday. You said that it was baby
basically poppycock. It's dumb. It was a
bad idea.
Um,
>> can you expand on on that and you know
cuz I I know that's sort of poison to
how a sock operates. So, uh, can you
expand on why the the whole AI powered
security team will just be a a failure
waiting to happen
>> because you have no judgment. You have
no idea of of context. You have no
responsibility
straight up. It's absolutely utterly
stupid. So you can't Okay, so for
example, I've I've developed a CCSP
course. All right. In the CCSE course,
I'm just I'm showing you guys how to
build an AI based sock,
right? However, that entire everything
I'm doing needs to have human
intervention.
It needs to have humans watching it and
see what's actually going on. These are
tools. That's what ultimately is. It's
not responsibility. If you have AI
making decisions for you and actually
acting within the sock, you're doomed.
Said you have lost your human
responsibility.
And then all you're going to do is say,
"Uhuh. I don't know what's going on."
Does not work that way. No. No. Let me
show you a book real quick. Beic. Get a
book. Yeah.
Doc
SK
>> SOC security operations center.
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> Yep.
So
a traditional security operations center
basically be a uh it's like a 24 it's
like the help desk of security where
instead of you
fielding calls from users and a regular
help desk for you know install requests
or something weird happened or um I need
I need a new machine or something. A
security operation center is if there's
a alert or there's a ticket that comes
in and needs investigation
from one of the uh security devices or
interfaces like um like a like a um a
seam uh basically a seam sim that's the
uh aggregator for multiple touch points
inside of your organization and then you
have a seam like uh Splunk is an example
to basically aggregate all your security
info into a single location. So, the
seam gets just puts all the info, all
the readouts into one spot. But then the
what that's but then after you get all
the info, what do you do with it? That's
where the sword comes into play because
now you're creating a a a runbook or
playbook, a a set list and structure and
you know basically you create a cookbook
like every single time a event like this
happens or event like this is detected
in the environment what happens you know
you get the you get the ticket you get
the ticket created you get the uh you
know uh an alert is sent out via email
or via Slack or something. Ticket is
created and then if it's critical enough
then something happens. Do do you want
to shut off an access to an account? Do
you want to contact the user? But at
that point that's a human interaction
and and that's part of the reason why I
uh raised a question because um a lot of
companies want to automate everything as
outside of executive jobs which that's a
different conversation but if you're
trying to automate security uh my
biggest takeaway was that you need
someone to be responsible and to be the
person that signs off on the security
move that was made. And if you're and
someone someone needs to when you're in
security, someone needs to have their
head cut off if something happens.
Someone needs to be responsible. And if
there's no one responsible for security
and a if AI is the one responsible and
cable for security, then it's already
it's it's going to be like, oh well, you
can blame the model. And the model could
be if if people want to find a model
cable, then that means they have to go
sue
sue Anthropic or Open AI and they're not
going to get the money back because
ultimately it's your company. It's your
it's your inputs, your runbooks. You own
what's happening. So that's why I asked
him about the AI security center,
security operations center because it
just seems as if it's a it it seems good
from a McKenzie consultant, but in real
world it's it's it doesn't hold water.
No, it it it absolutely seems it fails
Sarbain Oxley
>> because Sar Oxley states that a human
particularly the CISO or a seauite has
got to be responsible for all events
within a system within the data center
and uh if you only have AI running there
you don't have anybody that's not a
human being involved
you need I I don't know how they
possibly do compliance there besides get
a bunch of lawyers together and make
everything vague and um get it through.
Uh so this book this is here AIdriven
transformation of the sock and secops
was actually a very good book. I have
two other books here. I can't find them
which means I probably
okay read them quite a bit. Um but this
book very much describes how AI is being
used in socks sorry uh security
operations centers and what the legal
responsibilities are limitations and how
humans are actually supposed to be
involved in there. At least it's a good
starting point I would say. So go read
this book if you really want to go look
at this uh AIdriven transformation of
the sock and secups
right
>> a quick followup question
>> have a link for it I got the book link
what do you got tail
>> so basically if even if you create a v a
runbook for the AI if it runs into a
situation that is not in the runbook
book and it cannot extrapolate what to
do, then it's either going to you um
force it into something that's incorrect
or not going to do anything at all.
>> Yeah. Well, but I'm not even worried
about that. What I'm worried about is it
taking action and it's an extreme action
and no human is involved.
That's what I'm worried about.
Oh, absolutely.
>> Yeah. So, it's because not knowing what
to do, that's already a part of the
normal work the normal automation
workflows. So if you're talking about
like a SIM that actually has SOARE in
enabled inside of it or you put some
sort of SOAR platform inside of the
company, there's always going to be some
sort of work some sort of action that is
outside of the current workflow. So
they'll run books and so they have to
have a default action for that catches
all of that and sends it to a Slack
channel or something like that, some
some sort of notification for that,
right? the edge cases. Yeah, that's
good. Uh Carlton,
I'm not worried about edge cases so
much. I'm worried about known cases and
how they deal with them because they get
some [ __ ] going on. Okay.
All right. So again, very good book.
Recommend book.
Just so you know, uh, if if you guys go
to the enclave,
you see, you know, I have two copies of
this. So, I'm bringing one copy to the
to Vegas. So, I'll give it away
somebody, right? But, you know, don't
deny yourself a summer of learning just
to get it on the cheap from Theo to
Vegas.
It's only like 30 I think it's like $39,
something like that. That how much it
was? Not that much. 20 uh 20 with the 20
with Amazon Prime.
>> Okay, there you go. So, it's not that
it's not that bad. It's actually a very
So, we're going to get actual to the
lab, right? Okay, so
plus bedlock. Hold on. Another
Hold on. Let's see what this is. Oh,
yeah. I got this artificial. Yeah, I got
that book. That's nice.
Okay, there's a lot of books.
Are we okay? I'll take
I got a Don't worry. I got Chewbacca. He
has tea. He'll He'll deal with that. All
right. All right. So, SOAR plus Bedrock
AI instant response generator. Okay. Are
you ready? Because so we have here
unused token detected. So we have this
is what we're using. You guys did the
SNS last week. Good on you. I was
impressed with that. Okay. So again,
optional account disable, right? So AI
incident respon summary generator
workflow.
This how it works. Unused token
detected. You have event bridge lambda
gathering details. Bedrock prompt
generated AI creates crates security
analysis. And then you send summary to
uh Slack SNS. Okay. And this is an
example basically uh for JSON. So it
gets uh kind of input that's going to go
into bedrock or actually it's going to
go into event breaking. Okay. So this is
your bedrock prompt. Um this we get
bedrock enabled. We say you are a sock
security anal assistant. This is what
we're going to copy and put into bedrock
in order to get it to work. All right.
And this is going to be an example of
this. So what we want the example output
to be something like this. It says,
"Hey, severity is low, medium, and this
is probably why the token isn't being
used." And then it gives you um a
recommended action for this. All right.
So just something very basic. All right.
And here was what is your goal. You're
going to demonstrate AI enrichment,
prompt engineering, event summarization,
and so augmentation.
Now, this is just the beginning of this.
We're going to be expanding this quite a
lot with in a lot more areas. I'm just
trying to create the initial framework
so you guys can conceptually see this.
If we get this with many more you know
events, many more bridges, sorry um
event bridges and proper structure, you
can really automate this, you can really
um operationalize this in a large
setting and this is pretty valuable to a
company like for especially for a large
company. Okay, this is pretty good. So
you want to have you know demonstrate
all this but you don't want to have
particularly hallucination.
All right. And not just for dangerous
automation, unwanted automation or
automation you don't know what's you're
what you're doing with. So you're using
automation basically to ignore security
events, which is what we don't want.
Okay.
So hey, isn't this why you're in the
class in the first place? Besides
wanting selfies with Chewbacca, who
wants to selfie with Chewbacca? We all
want selfies with Chewbacca, right?
Okay. So here we go. Here. lab
objective. Uh here we have the token is
issued but never used. All right, this
is what we're going to do here. Let me
go down here.
Um there's a lot here. So first what I
need somebody to do is go into their
console and I need you to um automate uh
AWS. Sorry, I need you to go into
bedrock and I need you to turn on cloud
in particular. I want you to turn on
cloud sonet
and this is going to go down to here.
Hold on. This is I actually have this in
the lambda function. You have to change
your lambda.
This line is going to have to go in
there. It says enthropic cloud version
two. So I need you to turn on enthropic
version two. Now, everybody who does
this, if you don't have enthropic cloud
version two turned on, you may not be
able to do the lab today, which is fine.
I kind of anticipated that. So, we might
be doing the lab tomorrow. It might take
24 hours to turn on cloud version two.
Uh Rob, what's up? If if so thinking
ahead, if you made made a change to one
of the uh agents that you want to use or
one of the models you want to use the
foundational models, you would just
change this parameter here. So model ID
equals, you know, EMV var file or or
whatever. Okay.
>> Mhm.
So this is what you do this. Okay. How
it works. This line here tells you which
model you're using in in bedrock. But
this one right here,
this you have to modify this for
bedrock.
>> So in this case, your lambda actually
has the role to connect with buttrock.
If you don't have this,
this doesn't work. Yeah, that's the that
that will be the same for when we did
the Dynamo. You have to give we had that
that that was a big hangup. We have to
give Dynamo they have to give the Lambda
IM role access to Dynamo in order to
then allow the database rights.
>> Right. Right. That's correct. Yeah.
In fact, tape of truth. What I'm going
to do is I'm going to
in another section I'll just put one
area like for IM and say your your
lambda has to have this in the in the
wall before we do the lab just to make
life easier for this. I remember to do
this because this was a pain in the ass
to be honest because I was failing this
and I was like what's going on? it it
was this role it wasn't working
correctly and I was trying to get an ARN
to work cuz like I was trying to like
how does the Lambda know where to go
right it's like what the where where is
it how does it know which model to use
maybe I'm using multiple who how does it
read it where's the ARN how does this
work and I needed this that's just what
I was looking for okay so everybody I
need you to do is to go into bedrock
This is how you get to the bedrock.
Okay. Um, right. Where's where's my
bedrock? Okay. Console bedrock model
access. I need you to go into there
right now. And then I need you to do is
turn on uh go to claude and go to
sonnet. Okay. And turn on cloud sonnet
version two. The lab is built for that.
If you wish to do llama, I don't have
this set up for llama, just so you know,
but
I I may do this a little later on. And
the reason why you would do Oyama
basically, you can you can put Oyama to
be honest, you can get uh EC2 and put
Oyama on there. And the reason why you
do that is to create your own llm or do
a specialized llm and then you can just
have uh the role pointing towards that
EC2 and the oyama running there and then
you would just tell it the model ID
would be that EC2. So you'd point it in
that direction. The way the reason why
you would do that is you don't have any
cost then for running your own model
besides the cost of the EC2 which would
be nice and then if you have proprietary
information like my company has then
it's yours it's not public at all nobody
can take it it's only for you and this
is where you can start being aggressive
with AI you can this is where machine
learning actually really starts
happening
Okay. Fun. Was that good? I learned a
lot at the company.
Okay. You certainly did.
Model.
Oh, you don't have to manually
activate.
Oh, we we had So we So we had to
manually activate it for us doing this.
Yeah, I was. That's how I was doing it
before.
>> But if you But if you don't But if you
don't have to do that, Kevin, then
>> Good.
>> It makes it easy.
>> Yep. Okay. So, just go to um the model
then
and uh go to Claude and make sure Well,
it Okay. If it's turned on, it's turned
on. Okay.
Okay. And what I need you if you get
that done, then what I need you to do
is get this. Hold on. Wait, where's
>> somebody share their screen?
>> Yeah, somebody go and share your screen.
Um, your IM rule rule has got to be
modified. You you've got to do this with
the Lambda. you just got to do it. So
the lambda which is the unused token
detector
the role the IM role associated with the
IM the lambda for unused token detector
has got to have the bedrock allow in
there or else this is a nogo.
Wait.
>> So you're saying that people can't skip
over the bedrock web to do this web?
No,
no, you have this is the whole point.
>> Oh, sorry. I mean I mean Dynamo DB web I
misspoke.
>> Oh, no. You got to have the Dynamo DB.
This won't work without Dynamo DB. So,
at least we're setting this up. Now, if
you get the IM roll in, okay, and then
you modify your Lambda, then at least
you can go back and set up your Dynamo
DB. Now, if you are in a situation where
you do need to enable your
um your claude, I had to enable mine. If
that's the situation there, it's going
to take a while. So, that means you're
doing this lab tomorrow, which is a good
we had a good prep today and then
tomorrow we can actually
that's what I'm actually um
anticipating.
Okay. So, let's just try to get this
through get the infrastructure done now
and today.
Eva. Yo, Eva. Eva. Eva.
I have psycho dogs. Just so you know.
>> Well, a dog is representative of its
owners.
>> No.
Not like then that you cutie was me.
Judy,
>> you can have you can have multiple
parts, multiple facets, multiaceted,
man. Theodore.
>> No, cutie. That looking at somebody like
f you. That's what that's how Kitty was.
I liked her. He was great. I miss her
little bit.
Usually when I'm developing, I have her
ashes next to me.
and she's on the shelf and she's we'll
look at her every once in a while.
>> Oh, in the in the meantime, uh the bad
mind's here. Shout out to uh Jay passing
his security specialty.
>> Jay,
you've passed your security specialty.
Like, you actually studied and you did
it. I mean, am I are you at on an arc
with us?
Are you serious? You're on an arc? No
way.
>> Okay.
I thought you were just Dusty.
>> He's not He's not just Dusty. The bamboo
boat was calling him. He was telling him
to be a bamboo man first.
He was being recruited. Yeah, he was
being recruited to rub Kha down on the
bamboo boat.
>> I thought you were gonna be a Yeah.
Bamboo boat massager. and his and on his
birthday you see you saved him instead
of him on his birthday going on another
tour with with a 300lb w buffalo kha
he's in class got a security specialty
chat with us
you mean I actually have to share my
boat with you now you're on there so
this is your new bamboo boat right
you're actually on there with a with a
normal like you know you're you're you
actually earned your place. You're not
doing anything. My god. Makes face says
well congratulations Jay. Good for you
and happy birthday. I hope you remember
this day.
Hope this is a special day for you. You
look back and say, "Hey, this is what it
started happening. I actually got on the
boat."
All right. You like that boat? Do you
guys like the image?
I like this image.
>> It needs see I from last night you it
needs more attack of the killer weave.
They
last night they were going wild man.
They're wild
comic book memes of of sentient weave
like it was a symbio.
I gota I haven't used it online yet. I'm
gonna I'm gonna go attack people later
on. Like oh yeah it's great.
I'm back into Black IT Network with my
other account now. somebody.
>> Oh my god.
>> Oh,
call. That was a That was a 20 foot pack
of water for all them weave pictures.
>> Who did Who did the killer weave post?
>> Uh forgot who was doing it like last
night. Uh
>> Yousef
Sweeny. John Sweeny maybe.
There were multiple contributors. It It
was one of the more successful group
projects.
>> Yeah, that was
it was pretty devastating.
>> It was was horrible.
I was just I was like,
"God, yeah, other people can post them.
I don't mind."
>> Yeah,
>> man. Super bad with lace satisfaction.
>> Uh like are you really
Yeah. There's another one.
Oh my gosh,
>> this one with the multiples. I like this
one. This one I just posted. That was
just so That was just I mean, this is
Oh god. Oh my god. This
dude, I'm about to go nuts using this. I
am serious. like tonight later on if you
start seeing certain chat groups going
crazy, certain feminist groups going
absolutely batch crazy, just look to see
if I've been there. Cuz I looked at this
and I was like, "Oh, this is a multiple
target. Like this is mass chaos." I'm
like, "Ladies, you got you have no idea
what's about to come down the pipelines.
We're going to destroy you and like
ridicule you for the next 10 years,
right?"
So good. That was some good stuff. Um,
please modify. Yeah, turn them into real
posters and sell them. Actually,
Simpkins, I was thinking about for for a
lot of those just making them into
posters and giving them away.
I don't mind.
>> That's really That's really cool.
>> And then um some of them I want to put
into t-shirts. So, you know, if I get a
I could just get a spare $1,000 and get
some t-shirts,
right? Get some baller gym shirts and
then put that in the back.
Wouldn't Wouldn't that be bad if I did
that? Berica gym in the front and then
the back you have Wiki Beef.
Would I go to hell for that? Would I
enjoy it?
>> No. You you need to have uh you need to
have your uh you need to have that
modeled for you by a uh by a whatever
country you're going to land in.
Whatever country the c the gym will be
built in, you need to have like a 52,
you know,
caramel skin, blonde black hair, Latina
or tie chick model that she and she
can't be and like, you know, the shirt
has to be has to be going past her hips
so that she just wear it just looks like
she's wearing that.
>> Yeah,
I'm I'm bad for it. I'm totally I
I No [ __ ] left to give. None. I'm done.
So, hold on. We look at this one,
>> dude.
>> Let's get in there,
>> man. Put Put that Put that on Put that
in Japan right now. Right now.
Put that on a poster. Put that in
Shinjuku right now.
>> So, they like coming.
Oh my god. It's the Japanese is correct.
It's authentic.
Oh my god.
Oh, I like it. I like it. Au.
Oh, it's correct. This is real. This is
real. I like it.
Uh
This is good. Okay. See, we're we're
just we're just bad now.
>> Really?
>> What? Of course, I use my account, which
is does I know it's not free. Hold on.
>> You just need the right ad blocker.
>> No, my I actually have my paid account
on this one. My
no more stick. All right, I will listen
to this later.
Go back to here. Um, hold on.
>> Oh, did I buy that one? I think I bought
that one.
>> Yeah, Carlton, you're correct.
Uh, oh my go.
So,
if you guys really want you, how many of
you guys have been in Asia? I mean, I'm
sure you guys have been in Asia, right?
Um, some of you guys have like TIQS
have. Um,
Asian girls a lot of times would just
look at black women and say like, "I can
straight out take your man."
They did it with white guys, too. But
with black guys, he was much more
aggressive. And so if they like the
black guy, they're like, "I'm taking
your guy." And she would just boom, get
him. And you'd have a very plain looking
like a best B-cup girl.
She just so feminine. Just go get the
husband. Boom. Knock it out.
Okay, Kevin. Oh god, Kevin, whatever you
do.
That hair is alive.
Come out. You can do it.
Oh my god. How did you get the Japanese
to be this correct? It's totally
accurate. What are you What did you do,
Kevin?
>> Nothing.
>> Oh my. I don't know how you got this to
be this correct.
Only no com.
This is demon hair.
It actually means demon hair. Oh, this
is good. I like it. Oh.
Oh, God. Okay. So, yeah, we're all going
to hell. Guys, were you able to modify
your IM accounts? This is important. I
need you to do your IM role. I need you
to do that. I need you to turn on cloud
and I need you to modify your lambdas.
at least get that done and then we can
run through the lab tomorrow because I
have um sear one in
nine minutes. All right, I need to get
the infrastructure in so we can start
playing around with this tomorrow,
right? Because it's going to take too
long to do the Dynam to set this up.
>> We're just adding an inline policy to
our current Lambda RO. Correct.
>> Yeah. So your your current Lambda RO
Yeah. So the inline policy had That's
right. Just gonna do that here. Uh, make
sure that's added in. And then for your
use detector, use token detector. This
has basically this should already be
there. So it's this needs to be added.
Right.
Okay.
So once that's in there, you can start
actually using bedrock effectively.
We can't kidnap you and have you wake up
in Japan. Lick the handle.
No, brother on my arm. No brother on
your arm.
Yeah. Um
Jeff, I saw Again,
horist.
I saw one of the most devoted
um like religious
white guy couples in Japan.
They they thought they thought they had
a very strong marriage.
Six months she was gone.
Japanese woman took her place.
>> He he brought his lady.
>> Yeah.
>> Gotcha. And I always tell people, I tell
Westerners, if you're in a committed
relationship, do not go to Japan.
Japanese women will hunt you down just
the way they are.
They move like that in Japan. 100%
they'll do.
>> They move like that outside of the West.
>> Yeah.
You have to think about
>> you have to think about it. There are
okay, you have herbivore men, right? And
then you have so many men who just
aren't in relationships, even though
they kind of want one, but they're just
not in one at all. So, you have a lot of
educated, sexy Japanese women who don't
have boyfriends. Now, if you listen to
IEP, he's in whack land thinking that
they're all getting their freaks on. I'm
like, no, they're not cuz you you don't
have the population for it. So you got a
lot of sexless women, educated
professional women, right, who don't
have a man or they have no access to
getting a man. So
if you're a married man in the West and
you're stable and
you're happy, a Japanese woman looks at
you as a commodity.
They're going to go after you
immediately.
The man is automatically verified. he's
happy and she's going to be like, "I can
make you happier." She's not playing
around. She'll get him. She'll be like,
"I don't care if you're married.
You're banging me tonight." That's
what's going to happen.
Paying for boyfriend. Yep, that's right.
Uh Charles, what you got?
Do we need to add the inline policy to
all the lambdas? No, no, no, no, hold
on, no, no. The lambda, hold on. The
lambda ro policy, whatever your lambda
has a role, right? It needs to have this
polic this
added to the lambda role in the JSON.
Okay. Then to the unused token detector
lambda, you have got to add this code
right here.
That's how you do it. That's how the
modification is. Got to have that or
else this ain't going to work.
>> And which one does the first one go on?
>> Whatever role your role modify I am
roll.
>> Okay.
>> So you have to go look at your lambda
and say what role are you using for that
lambda to function? Whatever role that
is, it needs this to be added.
>> Yeah. and and you if you have so I'm
looking at prior labs we did we probably
used the basic execution role for lambda
you'll need to create a custom one so
that you can add in the dov
as well as now bedrock invoke model
>> y
>> are you kidding Carlton or you're a
black American
>> or
black American man, non-married, crowd
job, speak Japanese.
>> I remember when I was at AWS Japan and I
was doing that work, right? And one of
the Japanese Brazilian women figured out
that I actually wasn't married right
now. And she started talking to me and I
I actually told her what happened, you
know, that my wife died. I I say that
I'm still married to her, but and but
she she died and she was so touched and
she's like, "Go to Japan, please. I want
to date you."
Like, I'm not in dating form right now.
Like, I'm not I can't
>> Can I ask you a question about the
culture?
>> Yeah, go ahead.
>> So, I've heard that like the men are
expected to give their paycheck to the
wives and then they give you an
allowance back. Okay. But but you're an
American that would go there. Are you
expected to follow the same tradition or
that's only for nativeborn Japanese men?
>> It matters to what position you are,
what's actually going on with the money,
right? So,
>> okay,
>> if you if you're making quite a lot of
money, which I would suspect you're
going to be doing, you're not really
going to be following that rule,
>> right?
>> Okay. So, but just so you understand, if
you're in Japan, you're on her.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Okay. It's her hood.
It's not your hood. You're a guest in
that hood. So,
>> if she wants to get your salary, she can
get it.
>> Are you serious?
>> Yes. Do you know how she does it? Very
simple.
She just show gets her marriage
contract, goes to your bank and says,
"I'm the wife. I want access to the
account." Done.
She has full rights to your bank
account.
>> So, ju just understand
you're on her turf. You need to
negotiate with her. You're not going to
be able to do something like I have this
right or whatever blah blah blah in the
west.
>> You can't you can't bring American
concepts. You're you're playing the way
game.
>> No, you you cannot. And I'm actually
changing my view of like how how to do
the game of theory with with Japanese
women. I
>> using more rent pill concepts.
You can do it if you're making the
money, but if you have to make sure that
you're actually making the money.
>> Thank you.
Let me recover from this.
>> How do you How do you recover?
>> No, I said let me recover from your
answer.
you
essentially
how I say this otherwise if you're
looking
if you're using money at all in a
relationship in terms of a power dynamic
and if you're have any kind of
like womanizer
or you can get laid in this and that
fashion at all in Japan and you're in
relationship with a like any kind of
standard Japanese woman,
you all I can say to you is you're on
her turf.
Always remember that
you're not you are outside of your
element.
She is by far more powerful than you
are.
Never forget it. doesn't matter how much
money you have. Um,
>> that's devastating, Theo, to have
somebody take your check and give you an
allowance. That's devastating.
>> That that was Japanese culture from like
the 80s.
>> Yeah.
>> It's not just take your paycheck. She
can go in there and get every single yen
that you have that you've saved. No
during the entire time that you there.
>> Yeah. Because it's the remnants of the
high trust society. We trust a woman to
take care of the family, take care of
the house. That was her domain. That was
her job. So [ __ ] was baked into the
culture. And it worked until the ladies
didn't want to stay at home anymore.
They wanted, you know, Japanese style
feminism. But regardless,
>> it's just that's just the game. So
that's why they always said Japanese
chicks are pretty much some of the best
girlfriends, but if it's a wife, it's a
coin flip.
>> Um, they're they're not
you have to be very aware of what you're
dealing with. Just be just
not
know what you're know where you are.
That's the thing. It's just
Anyway, guys, I got to drop. I've got um
next class to do. Had fun. Please do the
modifications. We're going to run the
labs tomorrow. Uh if you want to come
prepared tomorrow, uh make sure that you
have your Dynamo DB up and that you've
actually issued the token. Then we can
go ahead and do this. Okay, good
introduction to sword. Uh, I I won't do
the introduction of the sword tomorrow.
I'll just go straight to lab. Okay. See
you tomorrow. Had a great time. Jenny
paintball boy.